okay uh so in the gu
you're you're coming and you're trying
to do the uh
goku nugget but when the person is
countering you
and you you lose you fail okay or
when we have the two attackers and
you're over here and you're trying to
muscle them you get pinned
and when you get pinned you get delayed
and the second attacker catches you
okay so we're going to go into that
technique a little bit
and so let's just look at cokiehole
and uh what's actually happening okay
so if he if i'm here
and i leverage him up
and then try to throw him
we do that technique like this this is
now i have been pinned
second guy is going to catch me
what we want to do instead is not have
two young
arms but one yin
arm okay
so i keep his energy going on one side
that's what starts to tilt
if you look here he's just and
so a lot of times when they're allowed
to counter
because his posture is not compromised
and he counters he can
he can do it especially when he lets go
double leg
oh then i'm in trouble
so the best thing is just do jiu jitsu
don't contest let the energy go by
and you'll see one shoulder straight
places and he's already going into the
front position
but i
am not just gonna let let him swing out
of the way
so i'll show you what i mean okay uh
you can let go and he's not
coming forward it doesn't matter
he i have the adhesion okay so
it's not a passive i'm here and i get
out of the way you see
because he has control of his feet where
he steps
only the choreography goes ahead and
checks himself
but if i don't have his body he can do
whatever he wants right so he goes i'll
move out of the way he does whatever he
wants any counter
so when we're not here i have to have
his body
so it is a yielding but there's an
adhesion which you guys should we're
going to show that
he's not pushing anymore and it doesn't
[Music]
matter
this is different
so usually they're coming forward that's
when you would do the technique
but just becoming just because he's
coming forward don't just
keep him in perfect agency
so we're going to have him not come
forward
and i'm going to do
the adhesion so yes it is a yielding
but it has integrity against other
angles
okay let's go okay so as he's coming in
uh you can see i'm on this side of the
of the uh
action sorry in this case your one you
were right
okay i'm not on this side and then i'm
pushing
so i i'm on this side of the thing you
see on this side and then
that is important because if i have to
be on
the other side of the circle all the
time and movement that it takes to get
there i don't have the same
control of his body i'm over here
this is where that all that's happening
secondly i keep your grip all weird
okay i don't want to use his
grip as a kind of anchor point
i do because that meant i gave him time
to grab me
and i don't want him to i don't want him
to get a good grip so in this drill he's
just here
and i'm good
[Music]
so a lot of times on the second guy
you're like they got a good grab on you
and the second guy got you so
it's all about boom don't let him grab
you when you're going into you
so i kind of feel fill his palm do you
see that
can you see that i'm not here
and up at his forearm so i'm going into
his head boom
[Music]
in this drill um
i'm gonna work on not letting him get
his grip
okay then i'm going to
test for the ikea adhesion
by having him pull okay
now the earlier i get that ike adhesion
the earlier i have control over his his
body you see
the later such that the more
it doesn't happen until i'm on the other
side of the circle
that's where you get counter in all that
time that he's moving
and you don't have control and then you
try to do your throw gear
like the counterable phuket
counters because you didn't have control
of them they're not
tilted there there's no angle
cancellation on their body
they're just walking in there's all this
is no control no control then he
voluntarily culturally
gives up his front foot in the way that
the countering
was that does not you get it
so in our drill you need to have the
adhesion
not there's no adhesion let's say and
i'm like i will i move forward
i move forward to here you see this is
too late
so you you want to try to get it as far
out as possible in the drill
so won't got it and then also as
early as possible so i'm out here but
look
tick tick
[Music]
right away and out as far as possible
yeah okay so
in in the push
we'll go back to the push but there
there's that same sense
that that's what's happening it's not
just me yielding out of the way and then
like i pulled the chair
out from under him and he fell down i
got out of the way and he came forward
that's not what's happening
okay so right away and now all i got to
do with that hand
is continue to take him into the shape
of the front
inward kazushi so don't
do don't leave it up here because i did
have the adhesion but i didn't keep the
tilt going
so tilt tilt tilt tilt tilt down
aware that the lower his head gets
the easier it is for the hip to cross
over
that line then less
energy or strength i need to
get him all the way into the kazushi so
if i leave this here
this hat has to go really far over to
make that
left hip take that geometry from falling
so i'm going i'm going to lower it
to get his head low
lower it to get his head up
boom lower
[Music]
okay this is where you'll return to your
external stuff all right and again
the guy's going to counter you or slow
you down enough to the second uk gets
you
right um or you just won't have the
mechanics for for doing the technique so
when you're you're over here and you're
going like this
this is all just leverage
right and so you you could you could
change
let's say i'm in the position right if i
go over here like this there's no
controlling him so this is where the
counter you can get does something else
to you okay
so here i already have control so we're
going to show that i have control
that he will give him different angles
so
uh let's say he wants to come forward
before i want him to he can't
uh and what you're going to see when i
say he can't is it
shifts his line of gravity and he has to
move his base of support okay
so uh in other words if he um
tries to pull back it's not that i'm
over here
it's that when i have the adhesion he
tries to pull back it
affects his line of gravity okay so as
i'm going you're gonna see that i don't
ever
get on to the other side and now make
this a push move
it's it's all an adhesion okay
so let's let's have him uh
lift up against the the adhesion
you see uh and we're going
let's let's have him uh try to bring his
foot this foot forward
yeah to get your face back under you
dude again
[Music]
so you have to watch the difference that
you're not over here you're going like
that
that will just go and it looks like it
looks like it's going to work but it
doesn't
as you as you've noticed okay so instead
it's here you have the adhesion
and you're just using that adhesion on
that hat wall
adhesion
okay as i do this
technique i i don't want to get on this
side and then
push this down it's going to be
a leverage move so
this this hand's got the connection
let's show it by
you resisting this has got the
connection
and what i'm going to do is you can see
that i'm making his mask move towards me
and it's going to hit the cochu so
he's going to come in again and i have
the adhesion on this hand
and i'm going to uh manipulate him so
boom he hits this hand
so again the ik adhesion
we'll do the one below we'll get on okay
so
uh i have the adhesion go a little
slower a little slower
i have the adhesion oh and this arm
here i want his weight to
hit that front ground path
so boom huh
he's pulling doesn't matter
can be long
can be short
can't get his head as low as possible so
the hip goes over
easier okay let's go